could you imagine somebody came out and
gave your kid a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich and a pepsi
no la you'd go to jail for that you
would be you hundred percent
absolutely but i don't know where the
peanut allergies come from but i've got
to be honest with you i'm [ __ ]
[Music]
looking
[Music]
i like la life i like um
you know i've i'm me i've been going
around i've been learning
the different things and people i feel
safe going into
east lake with the puerto rican because
i have a pregnant puerto rican so i feel
like that's like walking around with a
pitbull dude it's like
it's not a vaccination take the mask off
yeah yeah
yeah wow dude i just want to be honest
with you i don't know if you guys have
ever
noticed this but i mean you smell
amazing yeah i think what kind of color
what kind of cologne do you forget
what it is it's from france
oh yeah daddy
muscles i turned 38 last week i know but
but great how old are you 36.
my pubes are turning red oh is that what
yeah what does that mean
i don't know dude but i've i've noticed
now every time
i i hit the loofah on the pubes my pubes
turn red
wow might be the soap you're using it
might be the soap i'm using
you i uh yeah i i did use i'd like
use a little uh just for men you know my
hair like a while ago because i had
grace and everyone got mad
right i like that i just like the salt
and pepper i like the salt and pepper a
little bit i like it on you
it's very it's vintage you know it's
tough i like it dude
paul newman it's very paul newman do you
have
a gray hair chapel i have like a one
like single
strand right black guys don't
necessarily never grow great do you ever
see a gray uh gray-haired black guy
unless they're in their 80s
they have to and you know what i noticed
too you don't see
you don't see a lot of you see a lot of
tall young black men you don't see a lot
of tall
old black men no you don't see the like
like the guy like the guy who's six
you actually don't see a lot of tall men
old men in general you ever seen a 6
10 old guy like that's what i say you
never see a grandpa with
you know who's tall with tattoos and
cauliflower hair yeah well like i'm i'm
like a great dane
yeah i i ran out of a solid 15 years ago
are you gonna die early you think oh
yeah what do you think you'll die at 38
now
i would give me uh i better get starts
getting dicey at 60.
60 60. you think you're going to die
like a heart
condition oh you're going to get killed
what's going to happen 100 100 heart
[Laughter]
dude chin is 96 years old right now
and nick's been dead since the civil war
nick's been dead since the 1870s he's a
[ __ ] full ghost with headphones
we don't need theo
of red pubes uh chris got kidnapped
by our enemies who did this to you this
is this is who did this
i went i went to go meet with our what
which i thought was my good friend
andrew santino that's right
and i was tied to a chair and ball
gagged
and then they brought in andrei from
spain to come
and put a ziploc bag full of bobby lee
and andrew santino's pubic hairs
all over my face and it smelled like
whiskey and soy sauce
what yes it did look at this
yep watch oh
that's real slap that was a real slap
who is
oh yeah and he's from spain and this
tape was sent to ice
and we'll see who's going to be laughing
when he doesn't have his valid passport
what the [ __ ] that's the producer it's a
bad angle i have big thighs
is there a producer a mad scientist yeah
no he looks like he's on estrogen
therapy
andres look at his face it's rosy red
cheeks
oh dude yeah that's real puke that's
real
you know what bothers me about what i
mean you probably like the
bald gag that's what it that's i mean
yeah that's tuesday
he brought it i gotta be honest with you
it was one of those things where i
showed it i showed this like to my girl
and she was a little bit like
yeah i know like you do comedy she's
like but what are you letting another
guy pour
pubes on your [ __ ] facebook and she's
like do i need to go over there
and slap this [ __ ] around and i
was like wow like she like totally
emasculated me she's like you're like a
little [ __ ] yeah
you just let another guy put pubes on
your face she's like i thought you were
doing comedy
yeah and i was like so the producer
looks like a scientist transitioning
he does that's what's weird dude he
literally looked like he was on estrogen
that when i first saw him i thought it
was like an estrogen therapy
i thought they were going to inject some
of his hormones this is my issue with
that
is santino grown man bobby lee very
grown man
they decided to cut their pubes and then
uh
put it in a bag yes both over 40 where
it's like listen where are all adults
here if you want to get me back
tie me to that chair ball gag me and
then just come out your dick
and face [ __ ] me a little bit that's
what i'm saying because that's what i
was wasting that's what we're gonna do
to you bad friends
yeah exactly yeah
watch a little movie called deliverance
and you're going to see what's about to
happen
can you can you have your wife kick
their ass because they made me look like
a [ __ ] too honestly
what'd they do to you to nick i i [ __ ]
up and i booked stevie weeby on this
podcast for the culture corner
uh we're gonna treat them nice and get
some info out of them maybe
attack bad friends and uh we canceled or
we moved up the show last week from
monday to tuesday and i
forgot to call stevie and he showed up
at this
at the studio and i was at home no one
was here and he cried i guess
he didn't have a ride he hitched her eye
i found out because bobby text me
i was like dude what the [ __ ] i have
nothing to do with it
uh i fell on the sword though but uh
yeah they they kind of gave me
what they said
oh bobby's so mad i'm gonna act
really mad okay okay like furious good
like fear yeah not my project no it's
that way it's his brother
hello hey what's up dude hey what's
going on
hey man you're on uh you're on the show
we're recording you i just want to let
you know upfront be candid with you but
i got to tell you bud
it is not going good the first 15
minutes bobby has been just losing his
mind
he's been yelling because something
about his brother and you guys didn't
get him on the show and he's
freaking the [ __ ] out right now he's mad
what happened
man i uh i can ask you can i ask you a
question hold on
why do you do you disrespect me and my
family
no i honestly like when you look at
other comedians
you you probably respect them and you
respect their time
am i is it because i'm not funny to you
or is it because i don't have that
the respect in the comedy community or i
don't know what the [ __ ] the deal is
bro
that's my brother bro i know
he doesn't have money he [ __ ] got his
way out there
and he we are no no no no no no it's not
about money he doesn't want his money
dude
when he knocked on that door and you
guys
weren't there my brother [ __ ] cried
bro
it's disrespectful
and it's like i'm just asking you is it
did i do anything
personally to you to hurt you in any
kind of way because it just seems like a
[ __ ]
slam on me my career
right now too dude it's disrespectful
bro so can you
explain yourself there's no explanation
except that i [ __ ] up
see when brendan had nothing to do with
it i booked him we moved the show up
because theo didn't come back back from
nashville i
could not feel worse this is not said
ingest at all
what about a field what about this what
about a phone call
yeah they eventually were like we're
just kidding but uh i think bobby is
actually pretty pissed that
he was a little pissed yeah he
definitely wait so what what happened
though you booked his brother
yeah bob bobby lee's brother on the
podcast what is he
wrong what does his brother do yeah i
also don't know
and i'm not trying to be mean i also
i've never heard of him either
there's another body oh and nick gnome
he can come on i i don't i don't know
who he is yeah but the thing is here's
here's my thing bobby your brother had
taken uber here
for he didn't have money to get how do
you not get your brother a car
how do you not take your brother dude i
actually blame this on bobby
i would say i agree with you it's a full
circle you know what it's bobby's fault
for putting him in this situation
knowing the type of shenanigans that
podcasts go up to
so bobby i say to you you're
disrespectful to your brother and you
don't respect him and his podcast
yeah that's what i say and i feel like
your brother because i have your pubes
in my mouth
dude do you know there's another bobby
lee a cryptocurrency bobby lee
no dude look at google bobby lee crypto
there's a there's like a guy who's
verified on twitter his name's bobby
look like bobby yes
well i mean come on do the come on i see
times right now
i don't i know there's yeah okay
yeah okay yeah now now we have to do
that okay yeah now we can't talk about
anybody
right of course i'm sorry i apologize
here we go that yes
that doesn't you're gonna tell me you
don't beat that bobby lee versus the
other bobby league
[Laughter]
if he showed no i'm kidding everybody
stays quiet i know
what does he do he's the founder and ceo
of ballot crypto
ballot crypto rich as [ __ ] bobby lee
what world's easiest wallet
yeah there you go maybe we'll try to
talk to him next week yeah the other
bobby lee
do you think that it's culturally
inappropriate chin with all the asian
stuff going on that i don't know how to
use chopsticks is that a problem for you
should i learn how to use chopsticks in
an effort to say that i stand with asian
people i think it'll be a nice little
gesture but you don't you definitely
don't have to okay but i will because
your boy is nice with you i will
i'm nice with you and i'll give and i'll
give i'll give you a happy ending
no just because i want to show you how
much my community
you know so i want to do reverse i don't
want to give you a little jerk and i'll
use the chopsticks is that okay with you
of course most white people aren't doing
that so
100 percent dude that's what i want to
do to stop the asian hate is i'm going
to start jerking people off for 25
cash in parlors because some white
people are just like they're posting
online like
stop agent hayes no you're being doing
something i'm being
i'm being active being active i already
don't have any hair on my legs like a
chinese man
so that's good i have asian legs to
begin with i have my hands a little bit
bigger than my asian friends
but i still think i can grab a [ __ ] and
just do a little jerky you know
and i think i can do that let's see what
happens give it back man
i give back because like i agree with
chappelle says a lot of these [ __ ]
activists
it's just you're all you're doing is
posting a hashtag i'm getting out there
and i'm milking
i'm milking your milk i'm milking people
i'm making sure people are not going in
there with a fully loaded gun because
that was a problem a couple of weeks no
nobody has a fully loaded gun now i've
milked everyone and i've drained their
balls
and that's what it is hey cat how are
you welcoming stevie
i'd like to drain it what are you gonna
do what are you gonna do for cat hello
what's up cat yes because i'm talking
about i'm talking about with all the
things that have been going on with the
asian hey community as i'm turning i'm
going to turn around let's give it a
give back pause
back and i think i'm going to give happy
endings and i'm going to start jerking
people off so they don't go out well
with loaded guns that's what i can do
first we're going to call it christy d
gives back chris he d gives back that's
what i could do for people like chin or
or you know
uh other people you know transgender
people who now have a dick and balls
with whoever the whatever community
whatever community wants to identify as
having a penis and balls i will milk
their balls
for a woman though i'm trying to think
of how i can give back
right now i don't know what to do i'll
do your nails what about that
uh do you know how to do nails no but
i'd like to learn and i like
i'd like i'd like to learn because i
want to i want to identify
what about what else could we do we
could do nails what if you throw me in
the washing machine a little bit would
that be good
uh throw you in the washing machine i
don't know i feel like asian woman would
like men to do more chores probably more
choice i'll do chores
no no what if you put that ball gag back
your mouth and she like parade you
around like a dog
what about that oh that'd be great like
a water buffalo that's what yeah yeah
yeah yes yes or how about this you can
just behead me what do you think of that
go ancient samurai here's the thing we
tend to like to go
out with a bang with honor and i feel
like there isn't
much honor in just dying that's almost
like an easy way out right
well how about this vietnamese you can
throw some ancient orange on me
and throw it back at me there we go
that's different there you go you can
hit me with agent orange that's how
we're going to solve it so your [ __ ]
woke hashtags
suck i'm telling you out here i'm
milking the guys and i'm letting the
women throw agent orange at me that's
how you help
christie get back christy d gives back
and i've had enough of it
we're all together let's come together
you might not be good at uh
athlete at being an athlete you might
not be good at it
maybe the highlight of your athlete time
was doing field day as a child
and you had to run a hot egg on a spoon
over to somebody
you know big terrance or something and
he just you know he's supposed to run it
back but he probably took that [ __ ] off
the spoon and threw that [ __ ] into the
woods
and that was y'all's team but times have
changed
and now you can be athletic
and what's going to help you do that is
your greens baby that's right
one tasty scoop of athletic greens
contains 75 vitamins that it contains
whole
sourced ingredients multivitamins
multi-mineral multi-mineral
who wants to be a multi-mineral
green superfood blend they got it all
damn it they got it all
they can help it helps in digestion in
digestion
on digestion you got something in your
body that's never been digested
athletic greens will get it out of you
they continue
to improve this one formula based on the
latest research
that's right simply visit
athleticgreens.com
kats join health experts athletes and
health conscious go-getters
around the world who make a daily
commitment to their health
every day all your veggies all of it
all of everything you can imagine that's
green damn it's like swallowing a
freaking copy
your own yard visit athleticgreens.com
kats
get your free year supply of vitamin d
and five free travel packs today
when you go to athleticgreens.com
k-a-t-s hey guys you probably already
know liquid iv for their popular
hydration drink all right
how about their energy multiplier it's
an absolute game changer
one stick is like drinking two cups of
coffee it's an all-natural alternative
to processed energy drinks filled with
things we can't pronounce here
especially me or theo or christy d
or nick or chin or cat or chappelle all
right
half of americans report that they
struggle with daily fatigue
so let us take care of you man with
liquid iv energy multiplier
listen when i'm on the road nothing dehy
dehydrates me like traveling when i'm
flying
as soon as i touch ground wherever i'm
at maybe miami this weekend maybe
austin wherever i'm at i freaking
straight take liquid iv straight to the
dome i get a little eight ounce bottle
pour the liquid iv in there so i don't
have to worry about it anymore
i love it man we got you covered all
right liquid iv has cellular transport
technology
delivers exactly what you need to stay
hydrated man
so grab your energy liquid iv if you
have some energy if you just want to
hydrate we got you covered on both ends
they have it in bulk nationwide at
costco you can get 25 off if you go to
liquid iv.com
use the code cats at checkout that's 25
off anything you order when you use
promo code kats
look at iv.com start fueling your
adventures today
at liquidity.com promo code cats who's
who's this young lady nick debay club
i think we got our episode title christy
d gives back yes
there you go how about christy d's
cancelled
your cd doesn't have a job yeah yeah
right back to the pods
chrissy d lost the tv show adrian
and ahmad here from cincinnati ohio
uh we got engaged over the weekend
and we decided to go out and celebrate
with some friends so the first question
that the boys had was if there would be
strippers
at the bachelor party so we decided it
would be a good king and sting it for
you
so king understand strippers at the
bachelor party
and i have given him my blessing
as long as i can have theo as my
stripper for
my nashville bachelorette party let us
know what you guys think
theo gets the cheeks out for the cheeks
out i would like to have gotten a video
because this is just a white girl with
blonde hair from ohio when she's like
hey dad here's my boyfriend his name's
ahmad
zoom in on the father's face
[Laughter]
just like the curb he's like
what was his name aaron no ahmad
it's his name ahmad you're breaking up
babe
uh did you say aaron yeah do you have a
cold is he jewish
she probably he probably [ __ ] flipped
but look at it yeah no that was her face
you see how he's
that was her dad's face he was like
because no
yeah i hope he treats you well yeah um i
uh i was so i what is she saying that
she's allowing
i'm not so she's saying straight yeah
she's saying strippers yeah bachelor
parties
yeah and then she gets theo to strip
that's i mean fine dude yeah
now he might be crying like this
yeah i like i i would uh yeah i think
that's i think that's good i think
that's good
now jeff strippers are yours did you
have one no no
you're gonna have a bachelor party yeah
no why are you just like yeah i don't
give a [ __ ] dude
i live a life i feel the same way about
like fraternities and sororities it's
like what's the point of that like
you're going to make me
guzzle gasoline to be my friend yeah
well you're not paying for your
friends you're paying and doing dumb
[ __ ] just to be somebody's friend oh
yeah they pay to do it i don't know i
understand it though anybody been in a
fraternity
absolutely i thought you were what i
feel like every like generic college
girl thing you assume i did because i
went to usc
yeah that's just that's what you do at
usc well it's big there you go it is
really you guys like hanging out with
johnny
do you see usc basketball last night
they beat the [ __ ] out of kansas hole
really
they won by 50. my buffs yeah the only
my buffs lost but then there's an active
shooter in boulder that's what happens
though but colorado that's what they're
known for the active shooting they
created hey listen
colorado they're the first aurora
everybody is culturally
do you find do you get offended by
people culturally appropriating
mass shootings because colorado did it
first you have to ask yourself about
that
they did it i'm swinging today
there's been a couple of big misses but
what can you do
it's just one of those ones where they
just just let it settle bomb and just
have
brendan look at me have a cat and [ __ ]
and she'd look at me the only one
laughing is nick
let's move on to another debate
oh here we go look at this what up king
of the sting it's kirk from rhode island
back at it with another king intersting
it
this time we're talking gooey duck i
know cat brought it up a few episodes
ago
you guys got a good kick out of it but
if the opportunity arose
would you give it a shot or is that a
little bit too much shellfishing against
homosexuality what do you guys think
it's like a clown you know it's
basically
a big dick okay and what are you saying
do we you want a socket what are we
saying
would you try it let's
some girls will slap it before they bite
into it and it moves watch
it it's a saltwater clam
okay see that big thing you think you
tackle that thing daddy could i tackle
that yeah
um you know what if you gave it to me
today
my allergies a little bit so my throat's
a little inflamed but when i don't have
allergies and my gag reflex is better i
can do that
for sure i could do that do you have a
problem eating stuff like that like like
weird foods
like that um you know because i do you
do
i'd throw it probably yeah the only
thing yeah i could probably eat it i
would do it like for the show or
whatever but like
at home it's yeah i'm just i'm very
boring eating person it's like almond
butter bananas you know
things like that yeah just shitty stuff
have you had it cat
i ate it last weekend what what's this
yeah
wow what happened
[Applause]
big dick wow nick just so you know
you're supposed to clean them
before you eat them oh okay oh so they
have to be cleaned yes
okay let's go clean them all right let's
go clean it i don't know exactly how you
should i call my mom what country do you
think
uh we'll go clean these and we'll come
back i'm gonna wait to put mine on
we'll do another one in the meantime i
just don't trust that water it's sitting
in
i'm ready i have a few questions too so
what do you got
okay where do those things come from
nick uh h market in koreatown
h market is a good grocery store
grocery store cleanest one and but these
did these fly in from china
uh i'm not sure where they came from i
didn't ask a lot of questions i got
yelled at for taking pictures
absolutely who yelled at you as you said
the guy behind the counter they actually
had a sign so it's not we're not the
only ones to do that why can't you take
pictures probably some illegal [ __ ]
i i think i think honestly who took a
picture of the bat
i don't know i think i think people just
it's like becoming a thing online so i
think they're just worried about people
just coming in well same thing with
sprouts and whole foods you can't film
in there or target
you you can't film sprouts they're not
going to yell what do you mean why don't
they have like a sign outside
we can't like have a whole camera crew
like avatar 2 in there but you can take
pictures
of [ __ ] no because you know people try
to do viral video [ __ ]
yeah but you know what too out here you
know that i just had enough of
you know just waiting online to get in
the supermarket just go in the [ __ ]
trader joe's listen we know you're great
you [ __ ] are
oh you you maintain sushi it's in your
supermarket shut them i [ __ ] waited
online for 25 minutes
to go in and get cashew milk yesterday
because my kids lactose intolerant it's
just there were [ __ ] three people in
there
i [ __ ] hate the narcissist just
[ __ ] put around
look at me look at me look at how good
i'm doing with kovitz shut up you
[ __ ] i hope you get hit by a bus
i hate
if i see any more lines if i see any
more lines
outside trader joe's i'm gonna do
something i'm gonna
there's gonna be another active shooter
he's
i'm kidding i'm obviously joking right
but seriously traders [ __ ] you what are
you gonna do with those dicks
i'm gonna wash one do we want to bring
in one of our guests that's gonna give
us a live debate club and i'll wash it
and you guys can chat with them and wash
it
yeah i mean just run it over water
that's what i was gonna do that's what i
was gonna do what are we gonna have to
bite
into this honestly uh no i usually have
it sliced
you have it sliced so you've eaten this
before cat yeah i've i had last week
actually do you prepare
do you cook it or do you eat it right
you could cook it or you can eat it raw
like sashimi
oh it's like sashimi yeah and you like
it yeah because i don't you don't bite
it the way like those
women bite bite it off that's not how
you eat it well that's how they eat it
that's how they eat it so people will
think that they're eating a dick
that's why we enjoy it well that's why
you eat it i eat it
for different reasons you just like to
taste yeah it tastes fine
like when you prepare probably eating it
you grow up like mom and dad made that
for you yeah okay
but you never played with him as a kid
when your mom hadn't like slapped him
around what
really no how i would as a kid you
wouldn't [ __ ] with that thing as a kid
that would have been in my ass
immediately yeah forget gi joe's i would
have stuck one of those things up yeah i
would have rolled that thing in fruity
pebbles that thing would have been a
nightmare see that's why god put those
things in asian countries because white
people couldn't handle it
no we couldn't we couldn't although it's
all asian on youtube
let's be fair true there's no way to eat
it is sliced it's sliced yes
this is a very small percentage of
people who eat it like did you ever
bring it to school like to school lunch
like oh i got that no
like you want to bring seafood to school
like you wouldn't bring salmon as like
your lunch you know what i disagree i
gave
i get i didn't uh my daughter two weeks
ago
yeah i forgot to pack her lunch and it
was like 8 30 in the morning and i got a
fried calamari i gave her fried calamari
in a baggie for lunch
bad life now my school you're gonna hate
this about l.a you can't have nuts
shellfish uh there's a whole list
but can i but can i ask you a question
yeah cat how old are you if you don't
mind
25. you're 25 years old yes even you and
just be honest with you okay did you
know any kid
in your school that had peanut allergies
um maybe
like one three years after ever
never so where did it come from
where did where did where did this
peanut allergy thing kids follow the
sudden come from
either you know like when i was growing
up when brendan was going we were all
growing up nobody had peanut allergy so
did it just come out and
where where is it from one of our meals
twice a week at virginia court
elementary shout out to the tigers
was peanut butter and jelly sandwiches
tuesdays days and thursdays yeah
everybody ate it if you forgot
in my school growing up i went to saint
high school and ridgewood queen shout
out
shout out to pedophiles
i went to school there sister seraphine
if you
didn't she would give you a peanut
butter jelly sandwich and a can of pepsi
you would she would be put in prison
if she did that today yeah could you
imagine somebody came out and gave your
kid a peanut butter and jelly sandwich
and a pepsi
no la you'd go to jail for that you
would be you hundred percent
absolutely but i don't know where the
peanut allergies come from but i've got
to
[Laughter]
listen
on the video though they like roll it in
soy sauce or something
yeah you can dip it in different sauces
we have soy sauce
there's soy sauce nick's got soy sauce
are you gonna bite this
i don't know is it safe to bite are we
going to get sick
will you get a form of coffee i don't
know that i would do if i didn't have to
go
shoot for 12 hours i'd do it i need a
little nibble
i don't know if i could do it i would
wipe it you would wipe it yeah the
outside just wipe it just so it's
cleaner
it was washed off with this i mean what
would you do you're going down on a guy
and he pulls this out
like i'm not talking about a big penis
i'm talking about this this is what he
has
he's either an ally or very racist
andy has a homer simpson
so what's this
oh that's what is turning me on more
though look at that
see that the shape of that yes look at
that is that its ass
hi honey no one's being forced to do
anything they don't want to do do
whatever you're comfortable with yeah i
would do it
i would do it but i just feel like i
i'll take
[Laughter]
um all right wait i don't even know
where to begin to bite it
well it depends what you want to do does
someone want to step up for chris
i'm allergic to the show do you want to
do this just just i'll fight if you bite
it
hey okay go ahead jim of course i'll
step up
let him take care where do we find it in
the beginning
say well i'm sorry in the front we bite
it it's front or sides whatever you're
comfortable with you have you've done it
before
never you've never eaten this but i
watched it on youtube
you watched it so wherever it is okay
okay how should i eat it
i usually have a sliced i don't even
know this is uncharted territory for me
they just swap if you don't bite that
ding-a-ling already it's like bang bros
that's what she says yeah listen yeah
um a lot of you people out there are
trying to be
fake woke with your hashtags but i'm the
real chrissy d
stop the asian hey
it got me
you never see it coming
so no one's gonna swallow huh no one's
gonna swallow
all right chin are you kidding me he
[ __ ] squirted right down my esophagus
is this not am i not doing enough do you
not know that i love your community now
i just say to seecock
[Laughter]
oh good welcome back really welcomed do
you feel welcome
do you guys feel good about that these
aren't going to go to waste we're going
to finish them
just in case everyone's asking yes yes
we're going to chin's mouth is south
yeah we're going to
yeah we're going to finish these me and
chin and i are going to feast
uh should we bring in uh someone live do
a little live debate club
i gotta get it out i can't believe
people eat that is it that bad
dude they're not eating it right oh my
god
what's up bro
sorry what's up buddy how you doing wow
look at are you in germany right now
yo yo yo we got you now buddy what's up
man
what's up brandon not much dog you're
here with me and chrissy d
what's up dude what's up chris how you
doing brother
good man how are you how uh how's cueing
on
[Laughter]
i still don't feel 100
would you say we just say asian um uh
asian
go duck because we're in support of the
community so i don't know what you're
doing
i don't know how you're gonna give back
but this is what we do
you guys are clearly living better than
me right now i'll tell you that much
where are you calling in from buddy
uh indianapolis brother wow indianapolis
yeah what
what's you know what started there
indianapolis you know what started there
you look like one of them
easy with that killer okay well
let me check your searches what's going
on brother what do you got going on man
uh and uh ian's got a debate club for us
what do you got brother fired away man
all right look guys look so you're
driving down the street
you're at the corner you see that
homeless man with the sign
are you giving him a little bit of
change
are you giving him the cash money are
you just acting like you don't even see
him and keep driving
yeah i'm giving him an n95 is what i'm
giving him
i'll give him an 95 and say stay six
feet away buddy
i'll flick a coin at him like that no
i'll give i'll give him paper money
i would give them paper kids ash money
but you know what i probably you know
what i actually do
for for homeless people i give them food
i give them food them food i give them
food that's what my mother always told
me to do is go in and get them food so
if i see a homeless person
outside a store i'll go in and i'll buy
them food or coffee and most times they
will they won't take it because they
just want crack yeah
that's yeah you give them money they're
shooting it up in the veins
i give them a bag of cheetos maybe a
little sub you know that's what yo
chappelle's got a donk
on him i didn't realize dude between me
and you
and chappelle i think between me and
chapel we have the fattest assets in
comedy well you guys remember theo has
the biggest ass of all this
oh [ __ ] yeah you do have it that's all
right
you do have you got like
[Laughter]
dude nick is the kind of guy if i just
saw him waiting at a stoplight i would
give him a dollar
he looks homeless he's got that i was
just like oh and he's like what
what's this for man
he's like i'm going to work dude yeah
oh god yeah dude [ __ ] my day up i know
[ __ ] my whole day you give homeless guys
money man or what
yeah i'm not trying to i'm not that guy
that gives them food that's like giving
a child
clothes yeah you look like the kind of
guy that lights up on fire
[Laughter]
ufg look chris said meet me at 155
boy what you'll fight at 155 no no
that's what you look like you fight out
that's what you're telling me to come
down oh me
what dude i fight at 255
i'm [ __ ] what do you waiting i'm a
thickie um two
[Music]
uh 27. i'm like 2 30. i think i'm 230.
yeah
i need some thick boy merch i'm a dick
boy yeah yeah i'll tell you though
six feet six one i'm one of those guys
where it's it's in shirts sometimes
people or women be like oh you lay a
good body and then i take my shirt off
and they're like i wasn't expecting it
to be that loose
like one time one time one time a
casting director he was like you know i
was like doing it
and uh uh you know like in the casting
and he said um
and he said oh can you just take your
shirt off and i took it off and he was
like ooh he's like i didn't expect that
i was like yeah
and then i put he goes you know what
your problem is man you have leading man
face best friend body
he was like so you should just pick one
just pick elaine either get ripped and
be the leading man or just let it all
hang out and be the best friend
you know who has that problem is uh
gerard butler yeah cause he said he shot
300 and he was like
like all bodied up right so girl's like
oh [ __ ] that's
the spartan right they hook up when
they're like what happened
he's like yep that was a movie that was
a movie yeah dude yeah no i i it's my
nipples too i got fat punches
they got long nails i got long nipples
when we go to the gym i'll show you it's
just it's just a little weird when you
go to the gym with this one tomorrow i'm
gonna i know and when i'm done filming
next week eight a.m we'll go and then uh
bring the fam over too
yes that's what we're going to do we're
all coming over we're all going to do it
i just want to work out with stevie blue
eyes dick
i just want to do chin up talking
yeah that's my weapon like in street
fighter stevie blue eyes dick
yeah who was that guy who was just
driving was that just a random fan that
got in
uh no we're he's got a debate club for
us too but he's having trouble
connecting right now
really yeah but we've got another okay
that's what happens
what's up dude what's up this is ezekiel
what's good son
oh ezekiel bread what's going on brother
yeah i just felt a little different just
to stick though you know
yes how you doing so i have a
i have a debate club uh which
docu-series is better
that you know minnie aaron hernandez
danny hernandez
or that i got a story to tell by big
papa which one's better
it depends what you want because we all
know the biggies story yeah you guys
heard it a thousand times
yes but do you know the real takashi 69
story on showtime it's so [ __ ] good
and i'll be honest this isn't a popular
opinion i can't get enough of his music
you like working out oh my god what a
kawinki thing brendan has a show and a
special on showtime
show on showtime
the documentary the conscious stick side
i'm picking
did you see it i no i do when they show
that getting footage of him when he gets
robbed
when he's in the car and they have the
actual like taxi yeah yeah
no i didn't see that no i i haven't seen
the 269 but i did see the biggie one and
i thought the biggie one was [ __ ]
awesome dude i didn't realize how young
big he was and tupac when they died
dude i'm 11 years older than them you
don't realize
they died when we were kids so you guys
think they were like these old dudes
yeah i was i'm always like oh i
i still until i saw the documentary i
was like oh biggie was probably older
than me when he died but it's like no
it's weird weird is where biggie died i
mean we drive by there
yeah that's right really yeah right over
there yeah it was interesting too
because i didn't realize like puffy
being from harlem
he couldn't even go into that
neighborhood in brooklyn no
i didn't because because like things in
brooklyn are still like some
neighborhoods are but it's not like that
anymore like it's not like
like because like it's so everything is
so gentrified and diverse right now like
it's like there's people of all walks of
life all over but i didn't realize like
oh [ __ ] like
puffy has to speak through biggie's
people just even so
biggie man it was crazy the takashi one
too i know it's labeled as a snitch but
man when you look at the story
like in trey way trey way the tray way
bloods
who like they put them on and they're
like his security then they kind of
[ __ ] them over
they're the ones who robbed him and
that's when he got picked up by the feds
for drug trafficking racketeering
and he was like these guys just robbed
me well so he's like of course i'm
squealing well dude
i go to prison for life before i get off
in three i didn't see the documentary
but what i heard is takashi 69 like the
the tattoos on the face and the hair
that was all predetermined like he it's
all that
he did it for like the algorithm which i
respect he like
took you know what the new way to do it
is and just capitalize
that's what there was like all his boys
back in uh new york like this tattoo
artist and late who uh
dyed his hair they were like everything
was calculated like he wanted to troll
to get fans
let me ask you guys this let me ask you
guys this what's going to happen
first are we going to is lockdown going
to be lifted or is takashi 69 going to
be killed which one happens first
lock down lifted lock down lifted and
then locked down
yeah yeah yeah because i thought yeah
because
where where are you calling from brother
are you in vegas is that a vegas hat
yes sir i'm from that 702. i always
drive where uh tupac got killed yeah you
know so it's right down this
you know so every time you drive by
you'll get a little piece of history and
you know try to figure out how it went
down i'm like you i like going to the
places and after reading about it trying
to figure it out
brother you know where things are at
yeah the
the big and tubac thing's so weird
because you think you know neither one
more gangsters
right and then they're like talking [ __ ]
to each other and then they're killing
people it's [ __ ]
you know what a lot of money now is
biggie's mom biggie's mom inherit
because all that money all this
biggie still to this day biggie has an
estate still makes money
so at least you know it's not a you know
it's
you she wants her son but she at least
was able to make it
because he really wasn't making that i
mean he was making money but like not
like big
money like i mean state's got to be
worth 300 400 million dollars yeah
everybody samples his music and takes
his stuff
so she's good that's at least at least
they say tupac doesn't even
have that uh didn't even have that big
of an estate really
yeah well biggie to me in
at the time they were live tupac was
bigger than biggie but 25 years later or
whatever i feel like bigger he's
bigger he's more relevant biggie's more
relevant yeah because when like biggie's
like in the new spite well not new but
spider-verse like he's in pop yeah
the mystery is who killed both of them
right yeah no everyone knows who killed
tupac dude this guy looks like george
zimmerman his name was baby lane
that's he kind of looked like you got a
little you got a little incognito george
zimmerman
little george george zimmerman yeah
[Laughter]
thank you thanks for calling brother see
you later buddy
you know every now and then your people
are you know you're online
you might find yourself online you know
if you find yourself
looking at something and you're pressing
buttons at the same time and
and there's a lot of electronics
involved that's online
and if you sell stuff online well
then you're going to be in the right
business with ship station
that's right more people are shopping
online than ever
and you need to get a product to
the human that get that that desires it
well
ship station can help no matter where
you're selling
amazon etsy uh or your own website even
ship station funnels all your orders
into one simple interface man
you don't want unsimple interfaces bro
you is that what you want you want you
you want uh
you go to you know order something and
it's like a damn game of
megatron or something no so tighten up
man
shipstation has more five star reviews
than any other shipping
software small businesses can now access
excess the same rates usually reserved
for fortune 500 companies
just use my offer code kats to get a 60
day
free trial that's right two months free
of no hassle
stress free shipping just go to
shipstation.com click on the microphone
at the top of the page and type in
k-a-t-s
that's shipstation.com enter offer code
cats i'll be back next week make ship
happen ufc 260 is this weekend
stipe vs francis ingano the rematch
we've all been waiting for
it's here this saturday
and draftking sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the ufc
is putting you in the center of the
action with a special odds boost for
all the kingston listeners your thick
friend here put this parlay together and
it's going to boost the odds so you make
bank bro all you gotta do is pick
vicente luke
sean o'malley and francis and gano all
to win their fights all three have to
win the fights if two out of three wins
the fights you lose your money
all three have to win just head to that
now find brendan shop's picks under the
odds boost tab
doesn't matter if your new or existing
customer bet on it get your boosted odds
and ride along with your boy
plus don't forget there will be tons of
college basketball march madness my c
buster out of it sad story
but either way you can bet on match
march madness it's rolling all weekend
long
all new users download the top rated
draftking sportsbook app now
use the promo code kats when you sign up
bet on my parlay of fighters to win
saturday night
for ufc 260 take advantage of my special
odds boost
that's promo code kats only at draftking
sportsbook
must be 21 or older new jersey
pennsylvania indiana michigan virginia
only
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
call 100 gambler
or in indiana 109 with it or in virginia
888
532 3500. all right and this guy's
one of us he's got a relationship advice
question
oh he does god that thing made me god i
stink i i genuinely like i i probably
have to go home and shower
oh my god here we go and i didn't tell
my girl that i was coming to do this
podcast first
she's gonna think i smell like [ __ ] oh
my god
yes oh my god we have to
nick you have to send you have to send
me this clip immediately
immediately before i get home take a pic
with that big uh yeah
just tell her to watch the premiere 9
p.m thursday pacific
time here we go all right look at this
what's up man
what's up dude this guy looks like you
just made all this dress i love you guys
how you doing brother what are you what
are you a fireman
no i'm a truck driver oh there you go
do you ever jerk off in the truck be
honest you have a jerk
yeah i just did it right before i came
on here you got good bone structure
i thought you're wearing an earring but
it's an air pod yeah
what's your question brother uh
yeah so my buddy it's kind of long story
but my buddy
is dating this one girl and i knew her
since high school
and she was a hoe right and my buddy
he's kind of like a christian guy
and i is it kind of bad that if i were
to tell him that she used to sleep
around with all the guys
or should i just keep my mouth quiet or
i could be quiet because it's high
school man
you know what i'm saying it's so so she
got a little wild in high school
yeah dude
like the entire lacrosse team run a
train on or something
we're talking about 30 40 body counts by
19.
yeah i would here's here's what i think
here's what i think
here's my thing here's what i think is
the truth is you've had sex with her
and you don't know how to tell him
that's what i think is happening here
so we could just stop beating around the
bush and i don't think you should tell
your friend that you had sex with this
current girlfriend
nah man i've been out there but i didn't
go that far man that might not matter
i wouldn't say anything dude i mean he's
gonna see this you know so
she's a stay-at-home mom and he works
like 100 hours a week
so she pays he pays for everything and
then she goes out and buys a bunch of
[ __ ]
you know but do you think she's cheating
on him now all this stuff was in her
baby she got enough
dick dude one they say one's a cheater
always a cheater
is she but it's high school though it's
high school is she hot though is she
smoking
she's 25 she just barely got out of high
school
right and she is hot yeah i think i
think let
let relationships just let whatever's
going to happen with them happy with
them you don't got to get involved you
know
just whatever i feel like even people
that want to call out it's a home meetup
yeah i know
hopefully she's grown up and isn't just
looking for dick everywhere now you know
yeah yeah if she's got kids
and stuff yeah just she's all the time
that's a tough she's also yeah you got
they got kids you can't do that that's
tough yeah i'm with you dude
he's gonna see this and realize his
girlfriend's a [ __ ] back in the day but
yeah you'll be fine he probably already
knows though like i i don't think so no
it sounds like the whole [ __ ]
volleyball it looks the other way on
purpose kind of all right so then i
he'll figure it out i mean i i don't
know also people have sex who cares
everybody has sex
this christian guy found a monster
the christian guy found a monster in the
sack so he's yeah he doesn't know any
different he said oh my god
yeah yeah yeah jesus was wrong
and and then they have a kid but also
what are you gonna do you're like
hey dude your girl who you're happy with
in the mom dude back in high school
the football team all [ __ ] yeah but but
i don't understand like what
what's the difference like like okay lot
of sex back in the day who cares she was
who cares but she's not she's with you
now who's yours but isn't that weird
like
it's like if it was the other way around
like yeah do you think i should tell my
my friend's girl that he used to [ __ ] a
bunch of girls in high school like
no no dude i used to i used to ask those
questions all the time to grow like so
how many guys have you slept with
can i count on one hand two hands all my
digits
feet two feet two hands but now i just
like don't
care it's like whatever everybody has
like once you have kids i'm like
what's the difference it's like if i
ever broke up with my girl and moved on
to another woman i would want her to
have children so she doesn't just focus
on everything i'm doing she has so it's
like i would prefer the woman to be very
sexually experienced and
active when i was young and immature and
insecure
i'd be like oh you know it's like this
male ego thing it seems like an ego
thing jim would you have a problem you
found that your girl was just
really really promiscuous back in the
day when i was younger yeah
yeah i don't know you're older right
would you care
uh i just don't ask yeah i don't think
it would bother me but i just
don't don't ask yeah i don't it's like
where they are now it doesn't [ __ ]
matter who cares
yeah i'm dating stevie blue eyes well
see that's the thing it'd be quantity
for me it's quantity versus quality like
if somebody had like if you had if you
had
you know had sex with a thousand people
i'd be like whatever but if one of them
was stevie blue eyes i'd be like oh i
can't date you
i just feel so inadequate you know i'd
be like no not stevie blue eyes
uh who's this dying piece she's got a
debate club for us oh here we go
what's up theo and brandon i'm jax
coming to you from
sunny warm park city utah and i have a
little debate club for ya
if these two players were to play
against each other in their prime
who would be better michael jordan or
lebron james
gambling had sex with both of does she
like
them
she better make this
she has a sexy ass voice yeah she's
she's good gorgeous yeah there you go
wow that was a and that there was no
edits on that she really did that yeah
that was one
this lady's awesome congrats to you
smoke show good for you
before anybody says i think we did this
debate in like episode seven
but uh this video was awesome we had it
just exactly michael jordan versus
lebron james
well it's usually who's the better
player like who's the goat go
talk is stupid it's all about you know
time periods but you got to realize
here's the thing
if lebron james michael jordan played
you know how much bigger lebron is
that's the claim
so it's like lebron will probably
because it's just you could probably
body them up
different weight room techniques
different advances in general exercise
science
it's like the same thing with mike tyson
versus muhammad ali who wins in a boxing
match
you think yes but uh your boy honest
would go hard in the paint
he went hard on malik oh yeah he was
right he had the jordan facts
in his [ __ ] pocket and just lit malik
up and it's fantastic
really yeah oh with with how much better
jordan is that yeah he went
he was ready to go yeah i know he looks
like lebron
yeah and i was like this probably isn't
going anywhere because most comics don't
know sports
dude he [ __ ] he lit him up he went
[ __ ] were [ __ ]
for me the only the only reason why i'd
give the edge to jordan and it's a thing
that can't be measured is
every time he's made it to the finals
he's found a way to win i understand
lebron got there
eight nine times in a row but what three
out of seven and
i i understand how incredibly difficult
it is to win an nba championship
i get that but there's something i think
it's like an unmeasurable
science can't explain factor jordan
would will his way to win the
championships i genuinely believe that
because he went 6-0 and lebron although
he's a great champion and
and obviously one of the greatest
players of all time he couldn't do that
what jordan could do so in
if they played 101 even though lebron is
bigger and more jacked jordan may will
him
himself jordan has better defense better
defense it's a weird thing it's never
going to happen
jordan didn't jordan was a social
justice warrior so that's why he gets
the vote in my book did you did you hear
jordan wasn't a social yeah
he said how come he never give an
opinion he goes because republicans buy
jordans too it's like
facts here's the thing with what yeah
with stuff like that like i get athletes
having a responsibility
to do to say things and do all that and
i get they make a lot of money but i
just feel like if you're gonna die on
that sword
then i really better see your ass i
better see your ass
in certain communities you better
[ __ ] have a house there
don't [ __ ] run away to malibu yeah
with a [ __ ] multi-million dollar
house tell me
i want you [ __ ] there i want you
there everybody
don't go beyond your gated i know you
got millions and you made it in great
but then don't [ __ ] talk to me about
all the problems when you're in malibu i
don't want to see you tweeting it
i want you there buddy but yeah but
that's what nipsy hustle did right like
he stayed in the community well how bad
do you want it
it doesn't end well well what can you do
yeah you know i mean that that's
well i mean i guess you're right it
doesn't end but that's this is what i'm
saying
you know i'm too white for this
keep going i wish i could give [ __ ] i
just wish i could say stuff but i'm too
white
you bit the gooey duck you can now oh
wow yeah
what have you done for black people true
what have i done for black people
here you go what i've done for black
people here's what i've done
is um well number one number one i want
to i want to stay clear that
i have a diverse family i have i have a
diverse family uh puerto rican children
um because i'm you know i didn't want to
make more
all white children because it's it's
disrespectful to populate the planet
with more white people
so i went diverse that's number one
we're all so nervous number two
i i frequent dallas barbecue a lot
i'm always eating dallas barbecue um um
bbqs
in in times square i do that a lot um
what else do i do
i i think black church is better than
white church i can't believe that
you should sell tickets on stubhub for
black church i love black church
um what else do i do for black people um
i do a lot
that's i do a lot i um i didn't become a
police officer even though i look like
one
i did that i didn't i just got into
i got into the police academy without
even taking the test because i just have
to look i wouldn't do it
become a cop because i felt like no i
don't want to hurt my black friends
um i play basketball my dad was in
prison
that's a good thing that's a good thing
in solidarity i was papa in prison
papa was doing illegal things when i was
a kid my dad was mafia
racketeering and loan sharking and
things like that so here here's the
thing
on paper you know you would never guess
some white on paper
i got a single mom home dad in prison
and got a basketball scholarship that's
black black black okay there you go
so i'm obviously i did it
that's what i did for black people i
became a black person on paper
on paper out here i'm still why why
i'm like getting away with everything
white privilege
we've got another you walk the walk
my airbnb is three blocks away from
where one of richard ramirez's uh
victims was
really yeah right around here yeah
actually my new airbnb is in van nuys
that's what i'm yes oh that's not
come on that's that's and i zoom in
that's the hood right central all parts
of it there's nice parts i think i'm i'm
by the hood and van nuys
that's not the tv show's treating you
that's how this [ __ ] show is treating
me dude
well unbelievable now you have to worry
about it after this episode cheers
what do you got nick
yo what up brennan what up theo
and crew don't want to take up too much
of your time so i'ma jump straight into
it for you i got a debate club
and it's time to settle it once and for
all
which game is better for the n64
is it madden
or is it blitz gang bang
[ __ ] butt i think madden is just such an
iconic game but this is my shirt
i forgot all about blitz you hear you
tackle you did swing him around yeah and
that's when we get hit with like
exploding to bone
right the bones it was the nfl's version
of nba jam
right remember right yes yes yes he says
blitz
i feel like why i like blitz it's
because it's more
madden is a little bit like fantasy
football where it's like it's not real
it's like you know they try to be like
very pc where blitz is like this is what
happens to nfl athletes they all have
concussions they get cte their bones
explode
talk [ __ ] to each other talk [ __ ] to
each other blitz is what the real nfl
can you bring up the cover blitz i think
it was a steeler on the front or maybe
it's barry sanders
yeah by the way barry sanders i think
was one of the greatest running backs of
all time and retired way before
he should have he was cordell stewart
yeah
boy what are you fine unbelievable
dude my man he was there he was like
that like that all he could play every
position
you know you know he sued the guy you
know the guy goes i don't like
i don't like men's anymore yeah that guy
was great you know he came out and was
like yeah i sucked off cordell stewart
nice lied and then he got sued for 10
million dollars because that
that's where the rumors started that
cordell was gay and he was married with
kids so you
can't just yell like what's the rules
with that like i can't just say i sucked
somebody off if it's a lot if they're
famous because defamation of character
got it got it got it got it cordell
stewart stews to collect his three
million judgment over andrew deliver
caldwell's gay that guy is
but then he would post on his instagram
because me and chabelle got really into
him we went post instagram he's like
still
still doing it
and you know he's still straight as [ __ ]
he's glitter he has the [ __ ] sea
urchin [ __ ] right there
he's like love it just eating a little
asian food
but yeah he's always loves time he's
he's still claiming that he doesn't like
me he's full of [ __ ]
go to his instagram nick one more one
but that's what i'm saying that's the
type of fun you can have in a black
church yes
nothing like that happens in catholics
church i mean the fun happened
at night behind closed doors with the
priests there is oh look damn that hat
how many followers does he have 190k
190k is pretty decent numbers right it's
not
terrible for deliver for he went viral
he went viral you know it got like 10
million views he's making money
let's see that let's see the original
video nick how many views did i have
he has a lot of attacks on his uh ig
uh i'm
i think i'm that friend said we won the
podcast war just because you put pubes
on [ __ ] chrissy d
yeah dude we're gonna keep going we're
gonna i'm getting we're getting more
people involved in this podcast
it's coming at everybody do you believe
that the lord tonight
has set you free yes sir from the back
it looks like
chappelle's he's got the same amount of
magic turn around chapelle somebody's
gonna put chappelle's face
i'm not gay no more i am delivered
that bow tie says otherwise my man no
more
i thought i like women
do you think the other guys had any clue
he was gonna go into this no
they're like uh so we can tear up first
i would not
put on makeup is that what you call the
holy ghost
[Music]
[Laughter]
even that dance had a little sugar in it
dude you just can't shake it dude look
at that throw in his head be happy with
who you are man
well i think he is happy i think he's
like people looking like a
professionally openly gay man i think
he's happy being a gay man
his instagram says otherwise dude yeah
has to has the
lgbtq community come after this video
like because it's like kind of
painting being gay and negative oh they
don't come after black churches
good luck with that let me ask you this
real quick and then i'll go just
a thought light imagine let me ask you
this
final thought what because with art
right when we're talking about art and
things like this you know like a lot of
comedians
you know from tweets from 10 years ago
they get in trouble they said this and
it was
crafted in this way what about rappers
like how come rappers don't get in
trouble
for you know talking about violence
against women and cultural homophobia
what's the difference they came after
eminem who's a white rapper right
but they didn't really come after me
well they but whites did
yeah but he but the same you know like i
show uh you know he still performs like
people like you know
he can't cancel him but i'm just saying
they went after him right
probably because the music has nothing
to do with those people that's what he
yeah i i don't think they're going to i
don't think there's a comedian though as
a comedian though if somebody goes back
10 years and finds a tweet can i just
back oh you're the ghost writer like
what's the difference
he said all right somebody goes wrong
another rapper just being like you know
talking about you know [ __ ] hoes
i don't like gay people they're like
winning awards
so what's i just don't understand for me
it's like we're gonna have to make a
decision as a society what's art and
what's not we're gonna it's either has
to be everybody's allowed to say it or
nobody's allowed to say it has to be
everybody
it has to be everybody everybody it has
to be everybody no matter what you know
race religion creed you are and then on
this show before you get canceled i want
everyone to know you had a ghost writer
i have a ghostwriter yes i have a ghost
right here
my tweets really aren't that bad if i've
said it on a podcast yeah for the show
you had a ghostwriter
you had a producer in your ear he's
actually in the back yes his name is
andrew santiago did i say anything that
i don't know what you know that's the
thing we have to be allowed to do comedy
even if
that's what i'm thinking no you might
say that we have to be allowed to come
because
even even like with so many of the
issues that are going on like in our
country so many of our even fellow peer
comedians they're like i don't even want
to touch that's like no
we have to touch that yeah that's the
other
it has to be funny but look i mean also
too it's like now you're young at us
this morning and it's early but
well you gave me a diet [ __ ]
all right i gotta go do a show on true
tv if you want to see the real me
patreon.com says christy comedy
youtube.com slash christy comedy christy
chaos every tuesday
hey babe every thursday you're in l.a
for how long i'm in l.a till may 24th my
mother's birthday next week dude well
i'll have my girlfriend let's pick up a
[ __ ] fiesta
let's do it let's have a little fiasco
have the kids together yeah are you
saying that because my
family's uh puerto rican no my girl's
mexican born and raised oh look at that
they'll have a little fiesta we'll never
see that stuff
absolutely selena thanks this week
love you everyone miami miami this week
thursday friday saturday miami improv
get your tickets now and then austin
april 22nd 24th tickets on sale vulcan
gas company we're getting lit
take us to f-a-t-k-z.com christy d
we love you love you baby we miss you
miss you hope you're doing good
nashville brother miss you
we're out brennan and theo fighter and
wait i gotta go in and go hard in the
paint
i do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ate the queso and the quesoritos
but
everything's gonna be fine hate on me i
do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tribal couldn't beat him
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brandon's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
king and the sting king and the stink oh
yeah
king and the sting beast
[Music]
on a string